in this course we're going to build a
weather app called sunshine the main
screen is a list of this week's
forecasts with an emphasize presentation
for today's weather with just a quick
glance I can decide if today as a stay
inside and code day or if I should code
from the park instead we have icons to
indicate conditions like snow rain fog
or sunshine we can scroll through the
list to see a long-range forecast with a
click on one of the forecasts we bring
up a detailed view containing the rest
of the weather e goodness which also
gives us the ability to share the
weather with our friends we can go to
settings and change the unit of measure
as well as the location the app can even
post system-wide notifications to let us
know about weather conditions without
even entering the app so you might ask
why are we building a weather app we
chose the weather app because it's a
simple concept which touches most of the
core api's we want to teach and everyone
can relate to weather unless you're in a
bunker by the end of the course you'll
be able to use those api's and concepts
to build your own app for your final
project